it was my pleasure to introduce our next
speaker all right so good morning thanks
for coming so the very high-level
outline this talk is I'm gonna give you
a simple story about how probabilistic
programming automates Bayesian inference
and then I'll complicate that story
somewhat and let you in on some of the
things we're working on me and
colleagues trying to close the gap
between the simple story and reality so
probabilistic programming has two key
ideas least from this perspective of
this simple story one is that we can
represent probability distributions by
not by formulas but by programs that
generate samples and that that's a
formal representation so I shouldn't
surprise maybe people in this audience
and then the second key idea is that we
can build generic algorithms for
probabilistic conditioning that take as
input these types of representations so
code by describing distributions now the
other set of key ideas that come into
play here when you say apply
probabilistic programming to machine
learning and AI and statistics are
Bayesian statistical ideas and maybe
probablistic program is more general
than that in the beyond the simple story
but I'll focus on its applications the
Bayesian analysis so in Bayesian
statistics there are two key ideas I'd
say one is that you can express
statistical assumptions via probability
distributions so you have some data
that's steady enough there you have some
data and you want to make inference
about some parameters that might have it
did move a little bit okay sorry too
much coffee you have some data you want
to make some inference about some
parameters roughly speaking there's some
hidden state of nature that gave rise to
say causally or otherwise to your data
you like to make this an inference about
that but you don't you know these are
these are the parameters you don't get
to see now the Bayesian approach this
problem is you produce a distribution
over both the parameters and the data
and that is composed as
the composition of distribution on the
parameters that's called the prior and a
what's called a probability kernel or a
model or likelihood that describes the
distribution of the data for every
possible parameter sitting so that's the
Bayesian statistical setting your
assumptions about what is more typical a
priori that's in the prior your
assumptions about how the structure of
the world gives rise to the statistical
distribution of data that's another body
of assumptions and the second key idea
I'm probably say Kevin for instance well
it's not so much a key idea but it is a
consequence of having made this choice
to model parameters not as unknown
constants but rather as random variables
the second key idea is that in Bayesian
inference statistical inference is
carried out by ordinary probabilistic
conditioning so I have a Joint
Distribution I have some particular
realization of data X and then I'm
interested in this conditional
distribution which is called the
posterior and Bayesian analysis now you
combine these two bodies of videos the
idea is we're going to express our
statistical assumptions with programs
that generate samples so we're going to
represent this object here the Joint
Distribution by program and then we're
going to use generic algorithms for
performing probabilistic conditioning in
order to get at this object which is
what we're interested in so the
posterior distribution so just some
warm-up here so this is a very simple
problem sake Python program there's not
actually a I mean maybe there is a
Python probabilistic programming
language but I like using Python because
everyone speaks it the language I was
involved in producing bit bases on Lisp
it's based on Lisp and everyone hates
Lisp unless they love Lisp and that's a
very small set of people so so here's a
here's a yeah so here's a very simple
Python program it takes two inputs nmp
and it evidently calls this procedure
Bernoulli which I'll just tell you right
now so this when you call it with a real
number between 0 1 that that generates a
0 or 1 a 1 with probability P so it
informant formula we might talk about
flipping a coin with bias P it does this
it does this end time so it's going to
produce a
and Bernoulli random variables and it's
gonna take the Sun so this is just the
binomial representation so on the
surface it it generates a random integer
so that's maybe its type but it also
defines a family of distributions on the
set 0 up to n in particularly the
binomial family and then finally from
this Bayesian perspective it is ace is
is perhaps a a statistical model so a
kernel probability kernel describing for
example the number of successes among an
independent and identical experiments
each kind of succeeding the probability
P ok and then the inferential problem is
well I might model like I was intimating
a randomized trial by a pair of binomial
experiments there's some control group
and some treatment group now I don't
know what the success of the treatment
is or I don't know that say the the
probability that an individual will
recover from their disease if they're in
the control group or in the treatment
group but I can model those I can model
my uncertainty with distribution so here
I'm here uniform is meant to stand for
some kind of statement of complete
uncertainty as to what these parameters
might have might be so I can and so then
the composition these two procedures is
a Bayesian model of a randomized trial
but it's also it's not just math I can
run it so I can evaluate this program I
might get a pair of numbers 71 and 9 now
inside the program in the in the course
of generating 71 and 9 I generated also
P control and P treeman so I can look
backwards at you know because I ran this
code so I know what the numbers were and
the numbers were 0.67 and 0.86 now what
we'd like to that so that's not the
actual problem face the actual problem
we face if someone tells us 71 and 9 and
we don't we didn't generate that someone
else did
but we weren't then going to use this
model to try to look backwards and ask
well what were the likely values of P
control and P treatment and that is
inference and in this particular case
would be represented exactly by pair of
distributions
one for pee control one for Petri and
that's because of Independence all right
so that's the inference problem and the
way it will formalize it as well define
something called the stochastic
inference problem so the input in this
problem is a pair of programs one will
call the guesser and one will call the
checker
they're both programs they might consume
randomness in their evaluation and the
output that you must produce in order to
solve this problem is a sample from the
same distribution as that produced by
this program so this programs is a while
loop it starts off by making a guess the
first time around by evaluating the
guesser program one of this is one of
the inputs recall so we run one of the
programs you give you have given given
this program and then we take that guess
and we hand it over to the checker the
checker is boolean valued so we write
that to this variable accept and then we
repeat this loop over and over and over
until we get a guest that is accepted by
the checker and then that guess that was
accepted that's the output of this
program so this is a computation that
captures Bayesian statistical yes
inference this is exactly a rejection
sampling I'll guess in check
what's that you've infilling so to
translate into Bayes and statistical
terms guesser is your prior the
likelihood of a particular guess is the
probability that checker when handed
that particular value returns true and
the posterior distribution is precisely
the distribution of the return value at
this point in the program so this in
this is a computation that conditions a
distribution all right so a few examples
now following this to give you some
intuition so for example let's consider
a simple problem of inferring the bias
of a coin from a few observations of
that coin being tossed so again we have
our program representing the stochastic
inference problem and say a math were
given some sequence of binary values
they've been generated by some random
process that has some bias it's not say
probably 1/2 of getting at 0 1 it's
something else we'd like to report a
probability of say the next element
being one that's an inference about the
bias of the coin assuming they're
independent so in this case we would
model this or you solve it using the
stochastic inference problem or poses a
stochastic inference problem with a
guess or the form that returns a uniform
random variable say in the unit interval
so this is from I say a Bayesian
subjective Bayesian perspective this
would be a statement of a complete
uncertainty as to what the bias might be
and then the checker was the checker do
well this is my data 0 0 1 0 0 so I'm
going to go ahead and generate I'm gonna
this is this notation here means
generate 5 Bernoulli's and put them in a
list I had different notation for that a
few slides ago but imagine I had this
simpler notation all right so this is
gonna generate 5 Bernoulli's put them
put them in a list and then I'm going to
the checkers going to accept exactly
when this simulation generates the data
that I actually have in hand
do you mean I guess L to be
probabilistic or can you set the p21
value between zero well in order for
this to implement Bayesian inference it
has to be random otherwise
so imagine guesser is not random then
the output of this program will just be
whatever non-random thing you put here
so get if if guesser is non-random then
you know what guess is going to be so
there's not really any inference being
carried out prior you know the onset
then the Bayesian inference will not
yeah I mean so it's not path though it's
it's unusual it's not disallowed right
indeed in the limit so one thing - one
thing to mention is all right well
actually let me go to get sidetracked
quite yet it's really early Honka talk
guesser represents the prior oh yeah
yeah you can be certain anyway certain
it's one-half and then nothing here will
convince you
and indeed the choice 1/2 has
probability positive probability of
generating any potential string so
you'll eventually exit this loop and you
will report 1/2 and you'll be your
that's right and if it's incompatible
quality confirmation bias
I missed a question sir you're supposed
to report the probability no no oh sorry
are you asking about report probability
yeah it's not interesting that's a
probability but you need to report the
probability that you're very punished
the probability that that this is a
right para parameter for that for the
data probability that means the
probability solution that you showed us
okay yeah sir
so so this is a key point and maybe a
key difference between probabilistic
programming and probabilistic databases
say this program with these two
definitions this program represents the
distribution you're talking about I
don't need to repeat anything it that
code this piece of code represents the
distribution that is that is a
representation now you might ask what
can you do with the representation of a
distribution that produces samples okay
and evidently you can condition them you
can run them things like that so so one
question that I'm very interested in and
we're have worked with say Cameron and
Nate and various other people is what
precisely can you do with distributions
represented by code one thing you can
use run them but you can also compose
them with other distributions to to to
to effect those distributions for
example to condition them
I mean you can substitute uniform yeah
you could do anything you do you can do
here complete freedom right so yeah so
if you start with beta 2 1 here then
you'll end up this will end up being a
representation of a beta 3 2 3 4 5
that's a beta 3 5 distribution right
kind of estimating the outcome that we
can compute symbolically by hand on the
side I mean I chose uniform here so that
because not everyone in the audience
will know what I mean when I write beta
but I don't think this is not about this
is not about estimation yet yeah maybe
I'd like to understand your points maybe
you can just say it again differently
there's a computer algebra system that
will make all this obsolete and you can
compute directly answer on the nose yes
in that particular case yes and I
there's this dichotomy right between
working and compute PI and I'm very
interesting that gap
no competition well so so it's
interesting you could think about
inferences program analysis like saying
symbolically realizing that this program
with these two inputs will now be a beta
2 4 5 beta 2 5 but that's not how
imprints is gonna work so we'll see and
and and I said well that's too strong of
a statement you know in the simple story
program analysis and compiler people
sweep in and solve all the hard problems
like for example recognizing compiling
this down and realizing it's a beta 2 5
anyways y'all hear my opinion on that
later all right so if I run this program
so now so so this is I run this program
say 10 times and I generate I plot the
histogram like at this I run it 50 times
or 10,000 times so this this is
converging you can make that precise
it's converging exactly to that what
would be if I were to give a formal
semantics to this language is converging
exactly to what would be the denotation
of this program so that's what I mean
and so this is a beta 2 5 distribution
if you want to know what a beta 2 5
looks like ok clear alright alright so
if this is what we were going to do with
probably programming no one would care
so we're interested in more interesting
things and indeed given the flexibility
of this interface so sort of the sky is
the limit so here's a slightly more
interesting question it's a little
visual so how many objects are in this
image all right there's one object it
seems reasonable to say say there's one
object how about here so how many
objects are in this image
a little bit of uncertainty maybe even
if I told you all objects are
rectangular and have a single color you
know how many objects are here all right
it's a little it's not clear and if I
were to say move the I think that's
green out of the way and show you that
you might be surprised you're like ah
you got me alright so how can we build a
Bayesian model that would say reasoning
in a situation answer question like how
many objects are in this image so what's
our what's a guesser and what how do we
frame this as a stochastic inference
problem well so we need some model of
the structure underlying an image
because that's the question we're after
how many images so indeed we make a
guess we have some distribution here at
geometric geometric there's a
distribution and the integers kind of
gets increasingly unlikely so it's most
likely a zero then one than two etcetera
and then from this number of blocks we
generate blocks so we have Cius I wrote
some simple code to generate a random
block basically chose a pair of cornets
at random and I chose a color from four
colors at random it's a very simple
model sizes what is K so k is the number
of blocks I'm I'm making here a model of
an image I generate K blocks blocks are
going to well in my model I don't know
where the blocks are so this is a
statement of uncertainty as to the
location of blocks subjectively but then
yeah I'm generating random blocks all
right so my guess is going to be this
triple how many blocks their location in
their color and then what's my checker
if I want to understand this image well
I'm gonna rasterize I wrote a simple
piece of code I actually did this last
couple nights
which is why yeah anyway so I wrote code
to rasterize this collection of
variables so to produce an image exactly
like this and then I'm going to test
that it's exactly the same image
overlapping rows there's an order
implicit in this list and assumed to be
front to back all right all right so
when you run guests are you what do you
get and if you wrap if you rasterize the
outputs produced by guess what do you
get so this is this is a particular
image I don't know how many blocks that
are here cuz not really I'm not only
revealing to you the image you here are
some here are some images produced by by
guesser if I run it on this particular
if I run that if I run this program if I
view this is a stack inference problem
then I can run it I can run this
multiple times in order to start to get
a picture of what this distribution
looks like what this code what what the
denotation this code is right in here is
a here's 100 runs so this model believes
there are two objects here it's possible
there are three buts much less likely
what we're going towards here is say
well I mean it could be a one size one
block here another one here there could
be all sorts of nonsense going on behind
that block we don't get to see yeah
0 & 1 are impossible which is why thank
you that's a great point to make yeah so
these are impossible and this is just
due to Monte Carlo noise I don't have a
perfect picture here yes for the
distribution but this is a perfect
representation of the distribution the
code
so this leads us to what you might call
a fantasy example so can we extract the
3d structure from an image I show you an
image right I'm looking at Dan and I
have I can kind of I I can I know
there's the back of your head I know
you're not a I can estimate how you're
sitting and I could yeah I know I can I
have a sense of the shape of the room
even though I'm looking at a
two-dimensional image right that's kind
of amazing there's a lot of uncertainty
going on there it's a problem that mine
solves regularly so how could it be
represented as a Sestak I see
government's problem well the guesser
might well what would the guests are
have to have would have to have some
model a three-dimensional structure so
for example it could yes it's a model of
three-dimensional structures which
includes Dan so I don't want to get into
the details but how can you generate a
random three-dimensional structure and
this is chosen mostly to be easy to
describe from in front in front of an
audience but I can imagine like getting
a bunch of spheres that are overlapping
in some way and then shrink-wrapping a
mesh around it no one's actually done
that I just I used that because it's
intuitive and you could believe me that
I could actually write a program that
does that but now I have a guesser which
guess is a three dimensional shape and
what were the checker do the check would
render it maybe put it on top of a fuzzy
background and then if you had an actual
image it might do a pixel wise
comparison now if you demand that the
pixels be equivalent it's never going to
succeed or it would be extremely rare
and you and that's what you do it and
this is typical you you allow a little
bit of slack so that's the Ford problem
and then the reverse problem I show you
an actual image I run and then the
stochastic inference problem this
program represents a distribution on
structures and depending on the way the
structure of the guesser
I would expect this distribution over
structures to accurately capture things
I know as a human might be true for they
for example
if I was just willy-nilly throwing down
Sears merging them to get and then
shrink merging them together than shrink
wrapping a mesh around them there's
nothing inherent about symmetry so if
you saw a picture of me from the side
you went the process would invent
structure to explain the hand that you
see but it wouldn't invent any structure
to explain the arm you didn't because I
haven't Ivan Ivan insisted that the
model have any notion of symmetry but I
could build that in my model for my
model for three-dimensional structures
that could posit some symmetry if it's
not there I shouldn't expect it did
model that all right so I write fantasy
here but actually this has been realized
so Prakash men think it's just over
there as a group at MIT when they've
used precise this idea of generative
vision to look at for example images of
humans and to estimate the pose and
again certain baselines this blows that
away and so what is the generative model
so it's a little bit more restrictive
there's a there's a poseable human shape
what is the guess the guess is the pose
joint angles etc the checker is
comparing in some sense that
three-dimensional structure against the
actual image you can ask the next
speaker then all right but yeah that
gets that gets at the problem I mean
actually I think I actually think this
is reasonably efficient actually oh so
me me something something I haven't
really gotten into is this is not a
serious proposal for an algorithm recall
at the beginning that all I've said is
that this is this is this this is a
program describing the distribution
which you are responsible if you're
trying to solve the stochastic inference
problem it's your job to produce a
sample from this distribution but you
don't have to do it this way
you just have to sample from this
distribution or sample approximately yes
it's a mathematical code description of
the problem you're faced with but you
don't have to run this code
yes yes of course all right so a few
other things about probability this is
the actual picture handed to the system
and I'm this is actual picture hand into
the system this is a pose estimated by
the technique they're comparing against
so you can see a slight blue line here
so the the baseline method has indeed
found the left leg and here's its torso
here's the head so this is a reasonable
example but you can see that the
baseline has problems in some situations
like this is a football player picture
picture sorry is the name of the system
that does generative vision so this is
the pose estimated that in first yeah
exactly
sorry that was unclear but anyways these
these look very good yeah so a couple
observations about probabilistic
programs or programs that represent
distributions so here's a here's again a
very very simple program geometric takes
in a probability it it generates a
Bernoulli random variable it flips a
coin with probability P it stops and
returns zero otherwise it calls itself
and then adds one to the result so I use
geometric already geometric was the
distribution that I use to choose the
number of random blocks so this piece of
code represents the geometric
distribution with this particular mean
but note when I run this program there
is a probability zero path to infinity
or I keep say generating a zero right so
there's no finite bound on the number of
recursion that this program can make
what's going on here is that this this
program viewed as a function and then
and then kind of when we view that that
that function and say the framework of
computable analysis what we have is that
this what we're describing here is a
sampler that is not computable in the
the normal sense not total can people
rather almost everywhere computable and
and precisely this ability to run
forever is is the reason why this
promising programming approach allows
you to say describe open world
probabilistic models and this is
folklore it appears in a number of
papers we have a proof of it but it's
certainly not our result but the set of
distributions for which there are 80
computable samplers is a strict superset
of the set of distributions for which
there is a computable in the easiest
example I think Cameron even brought it
up already if I give you a source of 1/2
bias one half fair coins and I ask you
to generate a one third coin you can do
that but you can prove there's always
one at least one path through your
program that doesn't hold it's a measure
of zero path but just a curiosity so so
this is it so now I've taken that guess
or in checkered sebacic inference
problem code I've wrapped it inside a
procedure so now I have something I can
talk about condition so condition this
this this piece of code here represents
the higher-order operation of
conditioning so when if I if I kind of
restrict to just just for simplicity if
I if I restrict to the case where the
checker function is deterministic so
does that mean it takes an input and
returns true or false I can think about
checker as a characteristic function of
a set it tells you are you in the set or
out of the set input that's what's going
on so what is condition doing it's
taking an guesser guesser is
representing a probability distribution
P it's taking in a deterministic checker
say that's representing the indicator
function for some set a and what is the
output of condition it is that condition
distribution so it is a you know given
by this ratio but what we're
conditioning on a is being determined by
the predicate this works provided that
the probability the set that you're
trying to condition on is positive
all right so I mentioned this earlier
condition is not a proposal for an
alkaline what we could and then as I
said earlier this defines what the
stochastic imprints problem is it's it's
it defines the operation that we care
about well but even though it's not
serious proposal for algorithm we can
ask well how efficient is is it
algorithm so if we let say model B a
program representing some distribution
piece I'm gonna get away from guesser
and check but some of the model here is
kind of as a guesser then I say I was
some deterministic predicate for some
set a then it's elementary to to work
out that in expectation the number that
the evaluation of conditioning a model
on a deterministic product this is going
to take in expectation one over the
probability of the set a that you're the
predicate is representing times as long
as running the predicate itself on the
model here's what's going on there's we
just have a geometric situation we
haven't independent trials each time
we're making guess and checking it so
it's an independent trial might succeed
or fall and fail when we're talking
about how soon until the first success
that's a geometric random variable so if
the predicate model is efficient that if
this if this term is efficient to run in
some sense you get them
it's a I'll talk a little bit later
about notions of efficiency of random
samplers you know it's not gonna be pawn
in real time and the strict sense I'll
talk about that and if the probability
of the set a so if the in some sense the
checker is checking against data so this
is something like the probability of the
data so if the if the data is not too
unlikely but actually this will this
will be an efficient representation but
in the typical situation where you have
a lot of data when you have a lot of
data unless unless it's almost certain
what the day was going to be if you have
a lot of data then it's going to be
extremely unlikely P a is gonna be
exponentially small in some natural
parameter and then this won't be an
efficient algorithm
Margeaux
so on the checker for the coin example
it was not deterministic but he wanted
to make it deterministic then he would
move all that randomness into the guests
there so the guesser would guess a coin
and generate say five hypothesized coins
and the checker would just check to see
if those so suggest or the checkers now
take getting in a pair it's getting in a
probability value in a list of five
elements and it's checking to see if
that list of five elements is equal to
its particular the particular list that
it that is the data that answer your
question okay
I'm gentle you can always do that
transformation all right so so if
condition is not serious proposal for an
algorithm then what is what are we doing
in probabilistic programming so so
state-of-the-art algorithms are doing
something like what's described here and
a high level they're performing a random
walk so it's a Markov chain Monte Carlo
approach they're performing a random
walk in what space are they performing a
random walk they're performing a random
walk in the space of possible ways the
program could have run so when you run
the program it makes random choices you
can trace those random choices and
create a data structure representing
capturing the way that the program ran
so that's a you can think about that as
a point in an abstract space of traces
or ways the program could have run and
then we're going to perform a random
walk in the space constrain to be among
those ways that program could have run
that that agree with the data so encode
so we had a model that was our guesser
well I'm gonna reify it mom's gonna call
guesser before
okay so you had a you had a model I'm
gonna now introduce our model which is
that I are for reified so model had
randomness inside of it our model has no
randomness it takes all its randomness
as input okay makes sense so now I get
to control it from outside that's what I
need and then I have some operation that
acts on randomness that leaves the
randomness invariant so I have a way to
perturb in a measure preserving way my
randomness right and then technically I
want this perturbation operation to be
ergodic with respect to this
distribution and then how is this how
does this approach work at a very very
high level I start off with some choice
of randomness all right and then n times
I'm gonna perturb that randomness and
then I'm going to run my model on that
randomness that's like running Gesser or
running model I'm gonna check it against
the predicate if it if it's true I'm
going to update my entropy so I've taken
I have I'm at some current choice of ran
random input I perturb it and I accept
that perturbation if the data are still
satisfied yeah that is so there's two
answers to that question one is maybe
it's not our problem
all right and so you give me an initial
value for entropy which is not actually
random but that satisfies the constraint
another way and actually the way that
works in product and practice and this
really system computability results but
also it's just you have a set problem
otherwise you don't have hard
constraints so instead of for example
conditioning on the realization of a
gaussian being zero because that's even
impossible or say rather than
conditioning on the realization of a
geometric being for just charge me the
probability of generating that for okay
and that will be a function of the the
say the the the probability parameter
for the geometric and maybe that's the
output of my program so it
the output of my program is that
probability that I'm feeding into a
geometric and I have to generate it for
then rather than having the hard
constraint have the soft one and then
this is always possible and then this
equals true gets relaxed to something
else called a accept kind of accept
reject step in the metropolis Hastings
okay so so a brief word just go into a
bit more detail about this how this
perturb works in practice because you
could do this in a very generic way like
random here could be literally a
uniformly distributed random element in
an interval perturb could be some or
Ghatak transfer transformation leaving
an invariant and this would in principle
work we have all this information about
the structure of a program you've given
me the code that tells me quite a bit
about the structure of the program
something like something like and a way
that you can form oh is that giving me
the graphical model but it also has
conditional independence they'll says
local independence information so it's
richer even all right so I understand
perturbs we have to talk a bit more
about traces the traces as I was talking
about are these structures that keep
track of the way that the program is
unfolded so it's a tree data structure
capturing the random choices that have
been encountered in the evaluation of
the program and uniquely determines the
path that was taken by the interpreter
while about evaluating the program so
has looks so it looks something like
that it's a funny way of saying it so
this here's here's that here's a
depiction of a trace and and and this is
rather informal but I think about them
having two key parts there are parts of
the trace which are just about control
flow and the program evaluating this is
representing the recursive structure of
an interpretation of save a functional
language and then there are these points
in the program where you actually
encounter randomness and these are the
interesting ones in some sense these are
points in the program where you actually
encounter randomness so this represents
say the evaluation of the Bernoulli
procedure and this is just that
Bernoulli proceeded that the value of
that Bernoulli flowing up in an if
statement and this say control flow here
is well the Bernoulli is 1 or 0 then
that will affect which
branch of the if statement I take the
trace is determined by the values of
these random primitives so if I tell you
the value of this and the value of this
and that actually tells me the
straightest structure I know it and
changes to these primitives so if I were
to modify this value here then it might
cause the program to evaluate it in a
different way so how perturb is going to
work how we're going to move around the
space is we're going to reconsider
random choices and those by
reconsidering random choices that will
have follow-on effects and cause us to
take program paths we didn't take before
potentially so that's gonna be the
source of that's gonna be our Markoff
kernel that's going to generate a Markov
chain yeah yes yes yeah yeah and well
need is a strong word that's how the
first algorithms worked but if you
proceed this whole step with the program
analysis maybe you collapse most of the
program to some simpler computation and
then only unfold that yeah somehow you
need to control the willingness of the
code to go into infinite branches and
yeah there's this kind of entropic
explosion of traces of length and the
program do not get too
our goal you know you'll never be a
caddy
so the those two things so one if this
was the only if this was a Markov chain
actually then the other would be a
problem but it's this I haven't yet
described the for Markov chain the
program itself does not have that
explosion because the program itself
halts with a probability one and so it
is self controlled it cannot have any
kind of hub cannot have a positive
probability of an explosion or that will
result not in a probability measure but
a sub probability measure yes absolutely
for example this the this if branch here
it's just some simple computation but
you can imagine that huge computation
flowing flowing off the bottom of this
and so depending on which of the
particular branches you took you would
have one or two well you'd have a sample
from a distribution over sub traces here
and or a sample of distributions or over
sub traces there this structure is not
produced all at once it is you you the
trace represents how you actually ran
not the set of all possible
yeah and that's critical and that's
really actually that idea was already in
block block has a similar notion of
trace and in the idea that you have you
kind of only instantiate the variables
that are being talked about and that's
kind of analogous to this even if
different different and it's details but
that's the same ideas it was necessary
say for blog to work yeah
I mean yeah you can't enforce it by
condition or check because undecidable
you say it say that again there could be
a sound but incomplete permanence this
but but for that reason because they in
completeness we just say it's your
problem yeah for sure
and I think that's I mean people might
think differently but that's definitely
my philosophy okay determination is
probably one and yet have the like you
know it needs mean time of return oh yes
yes that's again that's sort of the
programmers problem if you create for me
a probabilistic model whose latent
structures are infinite in size and
expectation so you're asking me to do I
don't have any recourse that's what
you're asking me to do so so I'm gonna
so I'm now going to give you an
animation kind of going in more detail
up someone over here 100 yes hello it's
also worth noting that there are two
approaches being taken in the field one
which is kind of more like prologue a
declarative model where you just have
two complicit lis control all these
issues by changing how you write the
model and then there's other languages
which actually give you control over the
Markov chain doing inference or give you
alternatives to the Markov chain all
together more like an interactive C or
improver with a tactics language so it's
important to remember those program you
you know run them all contracted so to
speak okay or even use a different type
in infant strategy like we're kind of
speaker from Oxford I think we'll be
talking about variation
it's different a different strategy for
approximating the same basic problem
yeah so as I said in the beginning this
is this is the simple part of the story
I'm not showing any any of the discord
maybe and and in the complicated version
of story I think it's necessary to go
beyond assuming that we're gonna have
one algorithm that solves all of our
problems that sounds obvious because it
is alright so so here we're back to the
geometric programming and give you a bit
more detail about how this trace MCMC
works here's a geometric program it's
going to sample for me a random integer
potential infinite path now what I've
added onto is an additional computation
this is going to call geometric and this
is representing the computation
associated with checking that the
geometric has a value less than circular
less than three okay so there's gonna be
0 1 or 2
and so I'm going to represent for you
the trace associated with evaluating
expression alias geometric for some
particular value P right so I guess this
would be probably the second element in
the trace not the first one but say
we're evaluating a value they were
tracing the evaluation of this procedure
right then the recursive evaluation that
is interpretation will start creating
this data structure and right here is
the first point where randomness is
entered now that that Bernoulli is in
the predicate of an if and so here's the
computation associated with figuring out
which branch the if we're going to take
all right and then this here represents
the fact that there was a potential for
taking the other branch but we didn't
all right so this is a first kind of
point where there's some structural
randomness associated with the
probabilistic program we did not take
this path instead we created a another
recursive valuation of geometric we're
going to get some randomness again and
here evidently we do take that first
path and so
recursion will bottom out and now we're
going to run this alias computation or
to check our condition and see if our
geometric random variable is actually
less than 3 in this particular case it
is so this is a trace and there's two
elements of randomness and particularly
to calls it Bernoulli and if I tell you
these two values then the rest of it is
a deterministic function is so this is
really this this is this is in something
this is one way to name the structure so
I don't really have to store this whole
thing if I don't want to I could just
say store these two random values all
right so I'm going to collapse this huge
picture which causes my latech to
compile very slowly into this one all
right so I'm just highlighting the two
random choices and for this particular
model because the number of random
random choices I make exactly tells you
the the valley of the geometric that I
produce so there's two geometrics and so
the valley of the geometric was two and
the probability that I arrived to this
trace is P times 1 minus P now another
evaluation I could have gotten is where
it immediately halted and returned one
and that would be a trace that had this
type of structure basically this this
part would not have been like this this
would not have been there or I could
have sampled three-and-oh or so on and
we know from you know analyzing these
this model and you know elementary
probability class here is our
distribution of a geometric for generic
K and this computation that's
represented by this part of the trace
which tests whether the geometric is
strictly less than three that
computation returns true for only these
two traces so just sample from this
distribution like the sample from among
these two structures and I should sample
this one with probability proportional
to P and I should sample this one with
probability proportional to P times 1
minus P and instead instead of saying 1
minus P I'm gonna say P bar ok so P
times P bar so so proportional to that's
going to end up being well it's better
be P over P plus P times P bar
that's the probability sample one are
under the under this condition
distribution or vs. okay so these to sum
up to one so that's the actual
distribution they were after so recall
that we're going to do is we're going to
reconsider these random choices that's
gonna be our proposal but not quite so
here is a list of all the possible
traces I stopped drawing them after
three there's not six of them there's an
infinite number of them we're gonna do
is I'm gonna describe to you a Markov
transition probability that moves so
it's gonna be some probability that if
you're here you move here or stay there
or move here and cetera so I describe to
you these probabilities and the goal is
why am i describing the transition what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to take this
transition then I'm gonna take it again
and take it again taking again and if I
take it many many many times this Markov
chain will tend to be in some states
more often than others and I've
succeeded if when I run this chain many
many many times I'm in this state with
this probability and I'm in this state
with this probability so success well I
mean you have to define a notion
convergence so the chain I'm going to
describe won't spend any time over here
okay but it might be reasonable actually
to allow your chain to spend some well
actually the the type of algorithm I'm
describing you just cannot be out here
because well and that's because it's
stationary but you can imagine something
that's not stationary but still is
converging that could be interesting I
don't think anyone's working on things
like that
but it could be interesting okay so I'm
gonna describe this Markov transition in
two stages first is gonna be a proposal
and then we're going to fix the proposal
in some sense so the proposed that's why
I described earlier if I'm at this if
I'm at this current state I'm gonna
propose to reconsider this random choice
so this Bernoulli evidently came up one
that's why I halted so I'm gonna say
what's turn you what's
modify that Bernoulli and change it to a
zero so what what happens now
well I change that per new to zero so
now the interpreter says oh it this part
this part of the program that I should
have run so it starts running it
what is that it starts running a
geometric so that geometric might halt
after one step two steps or K steps so
this is a transition and these are
transition probabilities all right now
what if I'm over here
well now there are two choices I could
have chosen so I'm going to choose I'm
going to choose to either change my mind
here or change my mind here or with
equal probability so if I change my mind
here before I did a recursion if I
change my mind that means I don't do
recursion so I move to this state and I
moved would probably 1/2 because I chose
to reconsider this choice of 1/2 or I
could have chosen to reconsider this
choice which then caused me to start a
new evaluation of a geometric and I
could halt in one step two steps or K
steps this is an infinite number of
paths
now comes the correction part basically
metropolis Hastings tells me precisely
how to and in a way in in a way that I
can mechanically compute from the
program specification a way to correct
these this proposal so it turns out that
for the proposal starting from this
state I need to if I move ever move down
here to 3 or larger I actually reject it
and move right back so I started here I
made a proposal to something that's
impossible under the distribution I
immediately reject it
now this proposal sometimes moves to 2
or if this proposal also moves to 2 then
this time I don't reject it outright
sometimes I reject sometimes I keep it
and sometimes I reject it and then here
if I'm starting here if I happen to make
a move here then I always accept that
move and if I happen to make a move
outside of the acceptable region so in
not 1 or 2 then it's always rejected as
well and then you can collapse these
probabilities multiply and sum you get
this transition probability so this is
the actual kernel being implemented you
can collect these probabilities up into
a matrix this is a Markov transition
matrix you raise it to the K power this
is this
this tells you how does this system
evolve after K steps and then if you
take the number of steps to infinity
indeed a convergence to this collection
of probabilities which tells you which
is exactly these so that's that's how
inference works in these systems so by
you have a program it has made random
choices you reevaluate those random
choices which moves you elsewhere you
either accept or reject that
modification to the system and precisely
tune way such that if you keep doing
that operation of perturbing and
rejecting or accepting the perturbation
you converge to the distribution of
interest so yeah you can analyze this so
typically the systems are they need not
even be and they need not be discrete so
they're if you have to analyze it with
it's not just about like a finite system
with a spectral gap but you in practice
sometimes this works and sometimes it
doesn't
obviously so and by does work I mean
gives us useful answers and in in
reasonable time and the mathematics of
analyzing Markov chains as I'm a sure
fan Alistair's here I mean it's
difficult we're working on we're
typically writing down chains that that
we're nowhere near as a community able
to analyze theoretically so there's not
really much we can say in terms of
guarantees but but yeah this this works
surprisingly well or sometimes it
doesn't and that gets to the complicated
part of the story yeah
and whether you use the program
structure of course you used to generate
the trace but after that do you look
again yes when I when I decide to when I
decided to reconsider this random choice
what the the program is determining the
probabilities that I move to these other
states this is also this these
probabilities are also being determined
by the program yeah
and this interesting point which gets
gets to the more complicated story
different representations of the same
distribution will have it will result in
different chains some which might be
faster than others and that's I'd say
that's not a pathology of this approach
but actually like maybe our only hope
all right now for the real story so I
don't have very much time but it's good
I had a lot of questions I'm five
minutes
thanks so I'm just going to touch upon a
few things so what I've just described
this algún that I just described it
requires a little bit of structure in
the program in order to compute these
probabilities actually so this is
actually not completely generic you
can't just put any problems with
programming in the setting now it's very
very weak the assumption you put on here
it's something like well it's really it
gets down to this slide just how
generically can I say take it to take a
program representing a distribution on a
pair of random variables take a value
for one of the random variables and then
produce a program that represents our
samples from the conditional
distribution
I just how generically can we perform
that operation right so we've been
talking about things that kind of feel
discreet or there were some uniform
random variables but there's there's a
way to to talk very formally about
representations for distribution some
very complicated spaces continuous
distributions mixtures of continuous and
discrete so this is this is very general
so very complicated structures could
flow in here so just how generically can
we perform this operation and this is a
central summary so if it's discrete
that's always possible provided that
this data is not impossible
and witness to this being possible is
the accept reject the rejection sampling
out or them okay that's witness to the
fact that this is possible
no not efficiently but it's possible but
actually if you if you if you ask how
generically can I perform this operation
when the the variable that you're
conditioning on is is continuous that's
not possible
that's what Cameron talked about a
couple days ago so that you can encode
the halting problem into this well if
you add some noise that observation so
rather than conditioning on X you add
some independent smooth noise now it's
now it's possible again and this is this
is an instance of a generic structure
where you can have something arbitrarily
complicated and you can be conditioning
on something continuous or just heinous
and what you really need is you need
some variable s that separates the
structure that you're conditioning on
from the rest of the distribution and
you need to know a lot of information
about this representation so you need
something called the conditional density
and if you have that conditional density
then you're good so this is what allows
us to do something like infinite
dimensional Bayesian nonparametric
statistics and still perform conditional
inference this is continuous these are
all continuous that this is discrete
these are all continuous so I I can deal
with continuous if I add smooth noise
and that's just that that's a corollary
of the fact that I can deal with
continuous observations if I have a
variable that separates the rest of the
model from the observation and I know a
conditional density okay and you
basically have something like a Bayes
rule here I'm not gonna spend any time
in this but this is a picture of the
distribution that is that that shows you
things are non computable and so if I
try to condition if I try to sample from
the conditional distribution given a
particular vert on a vertical slice
that's not possible but if I were to
fuzz up this image by adding some noise
now it's possible what about doing this
operation efficiently well of course no
it's not even computable in general but
say if I restrict myself to discrete
case is certainly not efficient we all
know that but there are structures I'm
not gonna I'm not going to go down this
because I don't I'm but there are
structures there's the structure and
distributions which gives us some
leverage like conditional independence
so what is conditional and pennants have
to do with our MCMC algorithm is it
there's no it's not obvious that our
conditional our MCMC algorithm has takes
advantage of conditional independence
it's certainly not as explicit as say a
junction tree algorithm or variable in
the nation but when you have a program
that doesn't have very much conditional
dependence that's manifested by a very
very very deep trace and now those
proposals that say decide say I don't
have anything marked as random here but
like for example this whole structure
could be produced because this value
takes the value that's random variable
takes the value wants if I change that
now this structure disappears and after
generate afresh so these huge long
sequences around choices that all depend
on earlier things now this simple
procedure of reconsidering am Joyce --is
is making wild and very unlikely
proposals that are going to be typically
rejected by the metropolis Hastings
acceptance rejection step so when you
don't have conditional independence our
algorithm tends to grind to a halt so I
just wanna make this brief point because
a lot of the talks previously have
talked about the problem that inference
being the one one of computing
probabilities but there's a reason maybe
to prefer the formulation of inference
as a sarcastic inference problem this is
Tek stochastic immerse is about
generating samples and the reason why
that might be a reasonable thing to do
is because sampling is easier than
computing probabilities so you can so if
I have a distribution Moo stay on
strings let's keep it simple
the lexicographic order so I start with
the empty string then 0 then 1 then 0 0
0 1 etc let new prime be the probability
mass function so this is the actual
probability of the element X itself so
this is a distribution function the
cumulative distribution function this is
the probability mass function so we'll
call a distribution mu P computable if
the distribution function is efficiently
computable as a real function I'm not
going to go into how you can formalize
that but you can you can also talk about
mu being P sample which means that
there's a Turing machine that generates
samples efficiently and you formalize
that as you get the Machine some desired
accuracy and the probability that it
produces X and halts and time polynomial
in the accuracy demand and the size of
the value that it produces is very close
to the probability mass function that
you're trying to sample from is a
natural definition coming from average P
complexity I can make criticisms of this
definition in person later on but
there's there's results going back to
the 90s been divvied tour goal - bubby
and you know Mikami p computable is p
sample if and only if P equals P P so
maybe we should be going after
generating samples you can be fun things
with samples you can compose them
precautious thesis is is a great place
to look about the power of samplers in
terms of their compositional structure
and and so
so mute - okay - offices probability
this is less yeah for all X for all I
this is the probability mass function
that's a probability of the distribution
generating value X it's not don't think
about it is that I mean it is a
difference it is a derivative source but
this is exactly what you want this is
the problem if I sample from you then mu
prime of X is the probability that X
shows up okay I have to stop okay so
yeah I'll just up there thank you
I have a question about the metropolis
Hastings Fang yeah
Edom so so the promise of algorithmic
that there's some the steady state of
that Markov chain this is the thin
urinary procedure to evaluate the macro
camera on traces yeah we need to know
what it is trying to convert yes yes and
efficiently iterations are efficient
what's potentially not efficient is the
the the convergence rate thank you